faure l'ère du démission du ministère de
la défense paul quilès le remplace
associant aussi dans les services
secrets l'amiral lacoste chef de la dgse
démis de ses fonctions au moins 1000
morts des milliers de blessés le disparu
dans le tremblement de terre au mexique
un bilan aggravé par la pauvreté et une
économie malade premier festival
international de la mode à paris
rencontre de créateurs et d'industriels
du monde entier mesdames messieurs
bonsoir un fidèle de la jeune garde
succède au vieux compagnon de route paul
quilès remplace charles hernu
démissionnaire au ministère de la
défense des missions que nous vous
laissions entendre hier soir après la
lettre du président de la république au
premier ministre
rien rien sans famille la confiance que
la nation et le gouvernement portent à
l'armée
voyez bien que j'aie consacrer tous mes
efforts
dans une lettre à charles hernu un de
ses plus proches et plus fidèle
compagnon le président mitterrand lui a
exprimé sa peine et sa gratitude
il l'a reçu pendant une heure en fin de
journée daniel sportiello nous brosse le
portrait d'un homme qui a toujours eu
une passion pour l'art mais charles
hernu tire un trait sur les quatre
années qui ont certainement été les plus
importantes de sa vie
quelle réussite pour ce fils de gendarme
qui avait une passion l'armée que de
devenir un jour ministre de la défense
et de la défense il a une conception
qu'il ne se veut pas partisane pas de
référence au socialisme
quand l'homme de plume charles hernu a
écrit de nombreux ouvrages sur la
défense traite des affaires militaires
pas étonnant alors qu'il soit perçu
comme un ministre de la continuité
celui qui poursuit tout en accommodant
très bien d'ailleurs la politique de ses
prédécesseurs dans l'armée il a une
bonne image
jusqu'au bout il a couvert des généraux
français et le bénéficier d'une certaine
bienveillance de la part de l'opposition
sa démission coûte donc à françois
mitterrand qui perd l'un de ses
ministres souvent présenté comme le plus
qu habitables mais françois mitterrand
en garde un proche qui depuis la fgds
jusqu'à mes 80 en passant par epinay ne
l'a jamais quitté à l'heure de l'épreuve
je suis toujours votre ami at il écrit à
charles hernu un proche chasse l'autre
même si paul quilès ne fait pas partie
de la même génération politique il
adhéré au parti socialiste après le
congrès d'epinay
et très vite il est devenu avec fabius
et jospin l'un des trois lanciers de
françois mitterrand ahmed paul quilès
fut à la pointe du combat contre les
rocardiens et d'enfants ce mitterrand a
contrôlé le parti socialiste celui qui
s'est attiré au congrès de valence le
sobriquet de rober ce pôle pour ses
positions tranchées est tout désigné
pour donner le coup de balai qu'on
attend de lui dans la hiérarchie
militaire
jean auroux déjà secrétaire d'état aux
transports remplace paul quilès et
reprend tout le portefeuille organisme
de logement et transport cette affaire
d'espionnage qui a mal tourné est devenu
une affaire politique les réactions en
témoigne d'ailleurs et demain matin de
déposant une demande de commission
denquête alors plus seulement de
contrôler les services secrets mais d'en
quête sur toute cette affaire
parce que nous pensons qu'il y à là et
le parlement et les parlementaires de
tous les gros pontes à y participer à
faire la vérité que l'on ne connaît pas
encore
vous pensez donc il faut aller plus loin
car il faut aller jusqu'au bout il faut
avoir savoir qui pourquoi et comment le
chef de l'état a essayé de cacher la
vérité tout en la retenant il doit donc
s'exprimer clairement devant tous les
français
quant au premier ministre monsieur
fabius je lui renouvelle ma demande
comme président de la commission des
affaires étrangères et des forces armées
du sénat devenir devant la commission
que je préside
on s'explique et j'ai dit avant mon
départ au président la république et au
premier ministre que les blocages à la
vérité qui se manifestait devait être
surmonté devait être surmonté très vite
ce n'était pas possible que ce soit les
médias qui nous informent sur un certain
nombre de réalités ou d'hypothèses
j'ai fait des suggestions dans ce sens
je constate que des décisions très
importantes ont été prises
une sanction contre un haut responsable
militaire qui a cru devoir cacher la
vérité à ce qu'on m'a dit le ministre de
la défense charles hernu à assumer la
situation qui s'est créée dans les
derniers jours en donnant sa démission
je le regrette pour lui on peut
peut-être s'étonner quand même lionel
jospin qu' il ait fallu les dernières
révélations de la presse pour en arriver
à ces mesures on peut s'en étonner et on
peut le regretter mais néanmoins la
marche a été la marche vers la vérité et
je pense que ce qui est avancé ce qui
est important le rpr pour sa part s'en
tient à la déclaration de son secrétaire
général jacques toubon el radio la
démission de charles r lune ne suffit
pas la responsabilité du gouvernement
reste engagé l'attentât contre le
rainbow warrior a eu lieu le 10 juillet
de silence en mystère la faire ensuite
traîné pendant deux mois
l'opposition restée prudente cours des
choses s'est brusquement accélérée cette
semaine avec les révélations de la
presse eric pierrot c'est une révélation
du journal le monde
qui a déclenché le processus fatal à
charles hernu une troisième équipe de
militaires français auraient fait sauter
le bateau des écologistes toutes les
explications officielles données jusque
là c'est cool tu alors l'opposition
réagit rapidement
l'udf pour sa part crie au mensonge
aucune démocratie ne peut vivre dans le
mensonge
ça reste le rpr de son côté reste plus
prudent dans la soirée charles hernu
affirme qu'aucun service dépendant de
son ministère n'a reçu l'ordre de
commettre un attentat contre le rainbow
warrior au conseil des ministres
françois mitterrand kouroussa indiqua
charles hernu qu'il veut savoir
et dans l'après midi le ministre de la
défense fait une configuration à la
presse lors mal désobéi
si l'on m'a menti
je le ferai immédiatement savoir et je
demanderai au gouvernement d'en tirer
les conséquences
françois mitterrand adresse une lettre à
laurent fabius
cette situation est critique ne peut
plus durer le président de la république
exige des têtes
ce matin laurent fabius propose à
françois mitterrand de mettre fin aux
fonctions de l'amiral lacoste le patron
de la dgse et d'accepter la démission de
charles hernu le ministre de la défense
n'est pas le sol démissionnaire le
premier ministre a sévit également à la
tête des services secrets il a mis fin
aux fonctions de l'amiral lacoste chef
de la dgse familièrement appelée la
piscine mais ce n'est pas seulement son
chef qui est en cause c'est tout son
fonctionnement à longère derrière ces
murs hermétique
la piscine a déjà été secoué plusieurs
fois par des remous jamais bien élucidé
l'ancêtre de la dgse le sdec est mêlé à
l'enlèvement de benbella 1965 la sphère
benbarka sa conséquence directe le sdec
est placé sous l'autorité du ministère
de la défense et non plus sous celle de
matignon
la question est déjà posée qui doit
contrôler dans ces deux affaires comme
dans celle du rainbow warrior la
responsabilité exacte de la
archi n'a pas été élucidé car la règle
d'or c'est le silence un silence et un
mutisme à l'origine des relations
houleuses qu'entretiennent la dgse et le
pouvoir politique
après l'arrivée de la gauche au pouvoir
certains honorables correspondants
seront plus que réticent à donner leurs
enseignements
mais avec la fal greenpeace un degré
supplémentaire est franchie ce qui est
nouveau c'est que le gouvernement
constate publiquement son impuissance à
connaître et donc à mépriser les
activités des services secrets ainsi
l'amiral lacoste at il refusé de
répondre par écrit en invoquant sa
conception de ses devoirs
la question est maintenant de savoir si
après son départ et celui de charles
hernu la piscine livrera ses secrets
en intervenant directement et fermement
le président de la république a crevé
l'abcès mais on peut pas dire pour
autant phare de ré que la sphère se
terminer bah oui c'est effectivement le
problème qui se pose ce soir le fusible
hernu a fondu mais est ce suffisant pour
désamorcer complètement la faire sans
doute pas l'implication de la dgse dans
le sabotage ne semble plus flagrant
doute mais une question essentielle
reste ce soir sans réponse qui a donné
l'ordre de couler le bateau on sait que
monsieur qui laisse à huit jours pour
répondre
et d'ici là les enjeux politiques vont
s'exacerber et trois stratégies vont
s'opposer trois stratégies qui
apparaissent déjà ce soir on l'a vu très
clairement
tout d'abord celle de la majorité du
gouvernement il va s'agir de restaurer
cette notion qui d'après monsieur ferbus
la distingue de l'opposition cette
notion la morale le mot de mensonges
prononcés écrit lui a fait grand mal
mais celui d' incompétence lui est il
préférable
la stratégie du rpr qui ne repousse pas
une éventuelle cohabitation année
prochaine va consister à attaquer le
gouvernement avant le président de la
république est peut-être peut-être a
commencé à se déterminer
différemment l'udf hostile à la
cohabitation qui a indiscutablement ce
soir gagner du terrain et bien l'udf va
devoir chercher à éclabousser le plus
possible le président de la république
en réclamant de nouvelles têtes peut
être la sienne après celle de charles
hernu mais pour que le tableau soit
complet il faut dire un mot de la presse
pour elle pas de stratégie mais il s'est
passé ces derniers jours quelque chose
d'essentiel en france la presse est
devenu le quatrième pouvoir cher aux
anglo saxons
elle a fait son travail les radios les
télévisions centre
en conflit avec le pouvoir ont pu
l'amplifier cela n'avait pas été
possible au moment des affaires benbarka
boulin ou bien fontanet et ça c'est
plutôt réjouissant pour la démocratie au
moins 1000 morts des milliers de blessés
et de disparus
six mille dix mille on ne sait pas c'est
le bilan du tremblement de terre qui a
détruit le centre de mexico bilan du
séisme est d'ailleurs aggravée par un
urbanisme sauvage et c'est aussi une
catastrophe pour l'économie mexicaine
déjà très mal en point dans la clairière
et véronique bonnet nora dans la nuit
tout au long de la journée les équipes
de sauveteurs ont travaillé dans une
atmosphère de panique au milieu des cris
des gémissements et des hurlements des
sirènes une vingtaine de secousses de
faible ampleur ont prolongé le premier
séisme provoquant de nombreux incendies
et l'explosion des conduites de gaz la
solidarité de la population a été
immédiate et les sauveteurs souvent très
jeunes se relaient depuis 32 heures pour
dégager les corps ensevelis les enfants
particulièrement suffisamment petit pour
se faufiler dans les ruines
aujourd'hui le centre de mexico a été
bouclé par la police afin de protéger
leur travail la majeure partie de la
ville est sans électricité sans eau et
sans téléphone
mais la population reste informé par les
radios et des gars de catastrophe ne
sont pas encore chiffrés mais s'annonce
très élevé 3 et a dévasté plus d'un
tiers de la capitale détruite avec au
delà de la dévastation de multiples
conséquences
c'est toute la désorganisation de la vie
urbaine dans une agglomération de
plusieurs millions d'habitants entre man
10 et non seulement ces gens sous les
décombres mais c'est la panique pour
plusieurs millions de personnes ce sont
des encombrements sur les routes qui
peuvent durer des après midis des
journées entières n'est pas évident que
cette désorganisation dure très
longtemps on s'aperçoit que assez
rapidement les mécanismes fondamentaux
de la vie économique reprenne autrement
dit je crois qu'il ya lieu y alliez
évidemment toujours dans des
circonstances de ce genre de faire la
part il très dramatique et du trail très
présent où il faut se courir les gens
évidemment mais en même temps il y a
dans toutes ces sociétés je ne doute pas
que la société mexicaine ne soit comme
les sociétés méditerranéennes une énorme
volonté de vivre et de survivre au même
endroit une survie qui sera difficile
pour ce pays lourdement endettés qui
tente désespérément de sortir de sa
crise économique
le mexique vit depuis déjà trois ans à
l'heure de l'austérité
il a dû s'imposer en outre 81 2 c'était
le bon élève donné en exemple par le
fonds monétaire international dont il a
dû accepter les remèdes draconien
compression sévère des importations
réduction des dépenses avec des coupes
sombres dans l'administration lutte
contre l'inflation dévaluation du peso
des mesures qui ont entraîné une
dégradation du niveau de vie
en échange le fmi avait accordé au
mexique le rééchelonnement de sa dette
qui atteint 97 milliards de dollars à
des conditions impensable il ya quelques
années mais si le mexique finissent l
année 84 avec de bons résultats ces
derniers mois son économie se dégrader à
nouveau la raison la chute des prix du
pétrole dont dépend de 75% des recettes
du pays
un malheur n'arrivant jamais seul le fmi
va-t-il en guise de sanction suspendre
ces crédits comme il envisage
aujourd'hui à moins qu'à la suite du
tremblement de terre il se laisse
fléchir en accordant une aide d'urgence
en afrique du sud libération sous
caution du révérend père bouzac arrêté
le 27 août dernier pour avoir organisé
une manifestation contre l'apartheid et
pour la libération du lied
or noir emprisonnés nelson mandela le
père bouzac est accusée d'atteinte à la
sécurité de l'état fin du conflit de la
batellerie satisfaits des propositions
du ministre des transports les marines y
ont décidé de lever leur barrage avec
leur péniche il bloquait la scène depuis
un mois il avait aussi paralysé 70
trains de céréales sncf étant leur
ennemi juré qu'ils accusent de
concurrence déloyale
ils ont obtenu un meilleur partage du
marché avec elle et aussi de l'argent
pour réaliser la flotte
c'est du terrorisme
les syndicats cfdt snj la direction de
radio france condamne énergiquement ces
termes irruption ce matin à bastia dans
les locaux de radio france corse d'un
commando armé et masqué se réclamant de
l'ex flnc
ils ont séquestré être un journaliste et
l'animateur venot thomas dans un placard
sous la menace de leurs armes ils ont
obligé le technicien a diffusé un
communiqué de 17 minutes appelant les
corses à la lutte pour la libération
nationale
ils sont repartis sans être inquiétées
ce soir leur père demande des
explications au ministre de l'intérieur
sur cet incident le premier festival
international de la mode s'ouvre ce soir
à paris pour trois jours
ne pas confondre avec le salon chaque
pays a le sien ici dans festival des
créateurs et des industriels du monde
entier vont se retrouver emilie raffoux
et derrière les branches et les
classiques les sportswear et autres baba
derrière cette vitrine de look se trouve
une industrie colossal la seconde
industrie française après l'armement le
prêt-à-porter
des chiffres impressionnants 17
milliards et demi de chiffre d'affaires
une exportation en hausse de 25% par
rapport à 1983
dix sept mille employés un excédent
commercial de 2 milliards et demi bref
une industrie florissante et pourtant si
les professionnels de la mode se
réunissent c'est que malgré tout il ya
des faux pluie et des coutures mal fait
celle par exemple entre les créateurs et
les industriels un alliage difficile
avec des besoins plutôt divergents qui
sont rares à avoir réussi les deux ne
sont probablement par les seuls qui ont
à la fois contrôler la création et le
marketing etc en fait c'est sa belle
marquise mais c'est quoi c'est avant
tout un bon sens paysan qui veut dire
que nous sommes créatifs et nous avons
un bon sens connivence
côté création certains se penche déjà
sur les années 90 la compétition se fait
de plus en plus féroce avec les japonais
les italiens ou les anglais
alors pour rester la capitale de la mode
comme le revendiquent les professionnels
il faut encore et toujours innover voilà
ce qu'on nous propose pour les années à
venir
confort la journée sophistication la
nuit le problème aujourd'hui c'est que
chacune en fait plus qu'à sa tête
il n'y a plus une mode mais will mode
s'il fallait rêver un peu l'idéal ce
serait de pouvoir habiller chaque femme
pour qu'elle soit la plus belle et
qu'elle se réalise le mieux selon ses
rêves de quoi habiller à la puissance
mille pour satisfaire tout le monde
un langage qui ne devrait certainement
pas déplaire aux industriels nouveautés
automobiles maintenant peugeot va rouler
sur les plates-bandes de renault
il lui manquait un modèle capable de
concurrencer la héron les airs 11 et 9
et bien c'est fait ce sera la 309 dont
voici les premières images
elle est destinée à remplacer feu la
talbot horizon un tantinet conformiste
le style de la 309 renoue avec le
classicisme qui fit naguère le succès de
peugeot
sous le capot de 55 à 105 chevaux
selon les versions vitesse maximum de
155 à 190 kilomètres à l'heure pour le
modèle gt mais cela bien sûr d'intérêt
ce que les imprudents le dollar en chute
libre il a perdu 10 centimes à paris ce
matin et 20 ce soir à new york
motif la croissance américaine n'est pas
à la hauteur des espérances martin
thiébaut
pour le dollar c'est la douche froide on
attendait mieux qu'une croissance
économique américaine de 2 8% pour le
troisième trimestre du coup le dollar
déjà en net repli à paris avant
l'annoncé de ce résultat ne vaut plus ce
soir à new york que 8 francs 66 il
fallait s'y attendre autour de l'accord
ben il a fait un speech fini par
ébranler les investisseurs
il en profite pour critiquer le projet
de budget alors le moral tombent et les
cours des actions françaises aussi wall
street est également au rythme de la
douche écossaise décidément l' indice
dow jones n'arrive pas à tenir
durablement au dessus des 13 cents
car on reproche à l'économie américaine
de manquer de souffle et singulièrement
dans l'industrie
12e journée du championnat de france de
football de première division simav
seulement ce soir les cinq équipes
engagées en coupe d'europe joueront deux
miles avait besoin d'un peu de repos
voici pour ce soir les résultats on
remarque que paris saint germain a gagné
encore une fois il est donc invaincu
depuis le début du championnat conforte
naturellement sa première place au
classement
pour le reste je vous laisse lire les
résultats un match nul sochaux nancy 1 à
un autre match nul strasbourg marseille
0 0 victoire à l'extérieur de brest et
enfin victoire sur place de bastia ou
encore des chiffres cette fois ce sont
ceux du tiercé le tiercé demain à evry
dans les prix dans le plu d'auxerre les
pronostics de monsieur courtine
sur les vingt partants il a choisi les
numéros 3 2
c'est bien le 2 qui son joker 5 10 13 14
enfin le temps pour demain le matin
beaucoup de nuages près de la manche
sur l'aquitaine et la côte d'azur mais
après midi comme partout ailleurs
grand et beau soleil
du brouillard souvent le matin de
m'asseoir à vous avez quand même voir un
petit coup d'oeil sur les températures
et bien que vous voyez sont encore très
estivale
j'étais pressé de vous donner
rendez-vous à demain ce sera 21h55 après
le disney channel
tout de suite après ce journal dans
espace francophone un portrait du
président ivoirien félix houphouët
boigny avant de quitter le rappel des
titres de ce jour n'a pas demain bonsoir
charles hernu démissionne du ministère
de la défense paul quilès le remplace
émission aussi de l'amiral lacoste à la
dgs au moins mille morts des milliers de
blessés et de disparus au mexique dans
l'économie est déjà mal
une nouvelle que jours pour faire la
pige renault 9 et 11 la 309 mais la
concurrence étrangère sérieuse
non